[Musica]
ma porca di quella tutta quella puzza
quella puzza cioè presidente da cinque
minuti miei capelli sono diventati
inguardabili trump feccia della gente
ragazzi i valori di questo video sono
farisei ho aggiustato il problema dei
capelli perché non si poteva vedere oggi
in occasione dell'elezione del nuovo
presidente come se non facesse già
abbastanza ridere così può fare un altro
episodio di mister president dove ecco
infatti cosa ma ricorda un sincero
praticamente hanno fatto la cosa che
devi salvare donald trump prima che gli
sparino proviamo a vedere se riesco ha
fatto che non mi ricordo chi dovevano
fermato però c'è erano diventati
difficili livelli
bravo trump che sei stato che hai vinto
ma come sono contenti tutti quanti
tanto contenti fermi che non mi ricordo
non si fa sta rotolando come secondo non
si fa esatto uomo non si fa così vista
non ci arriva cosa hanno visto buttare
giù un cecchino e dall'altro mi chiamo
si è messo in una posizione che non lo
noti e l'ho buttato giù già fatta per
circa sono rimasto schiacciato ma va
bene non importa sicuro è anche i cactus
sono contenti di starò a lui non gliene
frega un cazzo mi ha votato trump e
tranquillo va bene e prossima scena cook
ragazzino veramente non mi son svegliato
stamattina ho visto sta roba di donald
trump
prodotto govou ecco la mia reazione è
stata più o meno perché è caduto un
tacco gigante qual è il problema perché
c'è una piadina secondo me sotto sotto
anche lui ha votato per tram ancora come
contento aveva ragazzini proviamoci
hanno capito se dovuto togliere trump da
questo
ecco adesso non lo posso schiacciare
piadine teste di minchia dove il proprio
da caccia andare cosa è successo a era
qua sotto
ringraziando invierà qua sotto si è
salvato perfetto ciao ragazzi voi non
avete votato per tramp e quindi mi sa
che lui gli ha messo alla porta
e vabbè frontflip perfetto l'unità un
atleta natale dovuto essere tu il
presidente sono tutte ma veramente ma
non lo sapevo mai va da parte di fatto
cagare uguale ma non è tanto per cui non
lo sapevo complimenti quindi io devo
andare di fronte flip continuamente che
figo ma allora sapevo che figata
lei per oggi o più veloce di così è
impossibile barca è vero a tensione
tac organo non ci riescono a buttarla ce
l'ho fatta
ma cosa cosa devo fare cosa come lo
tiene bene allora un cd si stronzo mi
chiamo ora che prova a far solo io non
avete idea che due palle ce l'ho fatta
io ragazzi in teoria avrei voluto
continuare con questi che sarebbero
quelli del wrestling che sono i più
belli in assoluto dove devo salvare
donald trump anzi ma devo fare non devo
salvarlo decisamente low fare tipo ecco
suo dio grazie a dio
l'ho preso l'ho preso quindi basta
toccarlo se lo tocco o indovini va bene
eh vabbè la [ __ ] la mira ragazzi
centrare il tavolo è una cosa che sa
fare solo benedetta parodi ma lo faccio
anch'io ripeto non so se avete mai visto
al breitling ragazzi non ci sono cose
che sono prese di queste e non esce sarà
un web come come fa uscire sangue adesso
perché è diventato un simpson donald
trump dei problemi chat e orange is the
new black voglio sentirvi urlare voglio
sentirmi urlare di più paghi
no mi sento ancora sono ancora vivo la
cosa ma chrome
va bene per fini non è finito dov'è dio
cosa sta succedendo fermi cos'è dov'è la
live e questo come ci arrivo devo devo
alzarmi conti fermino il quale ormai lo
schiaccia dai come fa a non essere morto
un per ci sono le cose non mi ricordo
che si possono fare tipo questa perfetta
ecco esattamente quello che volevo
vedere generativo più probabile carlo
così mica solo becco così me ne vado il
giuro è una promessa è una promessa
[ __ ] non me ne vado
definitivamente perché se non mi
tartassati di commenti che il video è
corto voleva bene a tirare un calcio us
tarocco ok c'è una scarpa una scala
perché c'è un salame giga ma cos'è eva
la 4a triste sto livello ma come c'è che
non ci arrivò mai nella vi aspetta
proprio fare mischia bellissimo non
svetta per cicinho riuscire fermi
davanti là davanti e mi chiama manco la
parte giusta rega ok
vai vai alla rai tony hawk tony hawk
perfetto ho preso mm porca [ __ ] fendi
porca [ __ ] scendi funziona funziona
seminativo a marca tra ce l'ho fatta ci
ha fatto ai paesi lo zio e zia sfonda
tutto suona tutto
l'ho preso l'ho preso no vabbè dai l'ho
preso
cosa ma no no va bene è morto è morto di
nuovo se pure di salva via adesso ve ne
andate veramente e tragedia o quale
problema devo schiacciare sta cosa
beh non è esattamente su promotore mi
così è in falso nome riesco più così che
come prima ok ci siamo staccati perfetto
questo volevo io
quanti problemi se va dai perché hanno
fatto sto gioco così trash abbia
effettivamente subito
in un gioco dove donald trump e con gli
slip effettivamente potrebbe essere un
po trash ce l'abbiamo fatto ragazzi
direi di provare a fare l'ultimo del
wrestling credo si è l'ultimo questo no
ma ci vuole alla madonna
[Applauso]
ok mica che tragedia questo
spaventatissimo non pensavo mai di
prenderlo
cos'è sta roba tosta ma per l'arrivo no
si aspetta la visita lasciato quasi
fermi che ce la posso fare cioè seno
becco ragazzi scavo un buco per terra
che arrivò in cina ecco dov'è ecclestone
al trump
donald trump vite parallele questo tipo
ginnaste prove ei ragazzi ho finito il
wrestling
credo sia stata l'esperienza più bella
della mia vita tra tutte quante prove
dei ragazzi se riesco a fare l'ultima
che normale non è non è che siamo in
cina ma dove io non anche l'ho visto
perché siamo in cina perché dei cinesi
stanno panini cosa cos'è sta roba è
lassù perfetto e non ci arrivo come
faccio ad arrivarci ma è impossibile
aspetta fermi perfetto bachi e api
spieghi perché ho dovuto salvarti la
vita con un fischio né che vale lascia
un fair
va beh ma mica che tu ma puoi metterti
con la posizione li maledizione buttati
da qui sta diventando sempre più non
senza ragazzi ma va bene così perché ti
sei messo lì dietro questo problema
perfetto che è caduto un barile in
faccia tipo di 800 kg ma va bene sono 20
ha ucciso più il barile che il
proiettile
perché se vicino ai barili porca [ __ ]
anche tu niente non ci arrivo non ci
arriva
ma cosa co come ma come mi becco il
proiettile fra non posso
l'ho preso veramente o che perfetto
signor tra proposto cosa qalcosa minchia
stai facendo
devo toglierti mentre cadi
ma dai una video è impossibile ma perché
ovviamente se cade su un pacco di
spaghetti giganti muore se cade invece
su sull'asfalto l'inno alli sopravviveva
bene molto toto minchia che presa ma
roman anche gigi buffon
tra l'altro ti ho fatto cadere anche su
un piano rialzato che è tanta roba per
freddo grazie ho vinto cos'è sta roba
non lo voglio sapere che i miei capelli
che non vedete grazie a dio adesso non
li state vedendo vi salutiamo e vi
ringraziamo per aver visto questo video
visto che è molto divertente il fatto
che trump potrebbe diventare presidente
con sé non ci crederebbe mai perché vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi come se mi è
piaciuto il momento è un mi piace a
capace di facebook e come da tradizione
sono stati scritti per i cibi chiaro il
prossimo video speriamo bella ragazza